well thank you very much appreciate this
reduction
to be back at Stanford I practically
never left you know I'm going to tell
you about more about my my story so we
have been always involved in one way or
the other with with lots of Stanford
related activities today I thought that
first I give maybe a quick background
about myself and like you know what I
did and where I'm coming from and then
talk about more about Genesis and what
you're doing there and opens up to any
questions that may exist so a Jeanette's
was the most of its digitised award
we're going to come back to it what's
the relevance to digitize the word why'd
they decide the word if is the DNA
sequencing company I'm coming I was born
and raised in Iran a country in Middle
East Iran and Iraq our neighbors even
though some people couldn't ly make a
distinction between the two but there
are two different countries and in Iran
I was born in a city called sphere John
in middle South of Iran in a little town
with 150,000 people and the history is a
2000 years old town or city the main
business of people over there is to
start your farm or is like a beautiful
Persian rocks called killing or getting
I was born in a middle-class family both
of my parents or teachers my dad was
teaching science in middle school and my
mom was an elementary school teacher
after I got my bachelor's and I got my
high school diploma in math and physics
in Iran you select and even in high
school if you wanted to study math and
physics versus biology versus channel
art then I went to Tehran the capital
city I got a bachelor's in electrical
during from sharri's University of
Technology if your electrical engineer
here I'm sure you probably met some
other people from Rice University as
well then right after that I came I did
a dual degree in petroleum engineering
which was just you know random thing and
then I came to Stanford
getting my masters both in EE and two
years later in MS any management science
and I got my PhD in electrical
engineering the last year of PhD I went
to med school
it's simple I really liked school but I
never finished that I started company as
janaab says and that's we the three
areas and she places that have been over
the past 15 years I have three brothers
no sisters obviously my brothers
actually they did very similar story
they got their master PhD also here at E
at Stanford one of them the youngest one
is postdoc right now here you probably
see him around the second-youngest which
is on the left side is working for Cal a
tanker he did his PhD with Marquis
failure in Kinston lab and Rahim worked
he's now a engineering research
associate at Stanford as well so he got
it master PhD postdoc here as well so
from that standpoint we always been
around we've been here at Stanford and
you may see them as the student here in
my past life
I was working on completely different
stuff I was working on radars and signal
processing hard core signal processing
wireless communication related stuff
actually I was part of the wireless
network lab in the third floor of
Packard building which was ahmed bhai
and andre goldsmith lab and there was a
very interesting project using it
multi-antenna laser imaging system using
multi internals
use w the ultra wideband to see the
signals behind the wall
I was interested in health care for very
personal reason a family member of mine
Co family member of mine was
misdiagnosed as pretty young age age of
50 and it was very disturbing to watch
how broken medicine is I mean when
coming to some conductor and when coming
to nanotechnology we're pretty advanced
I mean these do gadget the phones that
we have is really a miracle I said
before that Steve Jobs claimed to be a
prophet I was in his religion you know
this is really amazing what electrical
engineers have achieved over the past
two three decades we can move atoms we
can write IBM with a tin atom
but it goes to medicine we are still in
the cave age you know you get you get
different types of weird diseases and
like you know we just telling you that
hey you have like cancer I mean wait
what it was not supposed to be in fact
that dear friend of mine has a cousin
who the cousin Edith Federal
entrepreneur very successful PhD from
Carnegie Mellon computer science 35
years old and two months ago 35 years
old
two months ago got diagnosed with the
state tree brain tumor and it's not even
the type that you can operate it just
quit you know what separates it
basically but it's a thin layer on top
of brain and you know imagine that
you're like 30 or 35 years old or such
so on and so forth and then just telling
you that your state tree and you have
like a few months to live we know that
great people in fact were contributing a
lot is one of those times would be
professors one of the nicest people that
I've ever met when I was at school you
know got diagnosed with cancer at a
young age so these type of diseases are
really hunting us down impacting our
lives and we don't really know what's
going on and it was very disturbing to
really deal with that concept why
medicine is still so behind what
medicine still in the cave age so after
learning but more learning more about
genomics and DNA sequencing and when you
dig in basically in the world of biology
we the highest resolution
and things that you have is like
molecules
kliklak acid which is DNA RNA then from
RNA is it creating proteins proteins are
the one who is defining the function of
the cell and then you have cells which
is like you know bunch of cells creating
origins and the rest of these as already
so majority of these diseases having
some sort of genomic cause or a genetic
relevance different type of cancers
cancer ease DNA disease cancer is when
the DNA is lecture 80 see Jesus not
happening in the right place majority of
the time is DNA but also RNA we have the
same thing also in the protein level so
drug molecule and these molecules are
really teeny tiny a DNA molecule like we
have about 38 trillion cells in our body
each cell has DNA DNA of the whole DNA
of a human for each cell is 6.4 billion
base per atcg
and so it's a lot of information and we
all started from one cell like going in
a fetus and let's start replicating 1 to
2 2 to 4 4 to 16 and so on and so forth
and now we are 38 trillion cells and
every moment of time we have like you
know billions of new cells that is
really happening
these process like any other process in
the world is not perfect so the errors
happening in this the process of like
replication of one cell to two cell so
you have this DNA in the double helix as
you know it's get single-stranded and
the second strand get built up these
process with enzyme that is trying to
really build the second DNA their first
enzyme error is 10 to the minus 7
there's a second enzyme coming trying to
clean the some errors up and that's
about 10 to minus 2 so if everything
works really perfectly then you have
about 10 to the minus 9 error rate and
of course you have 6 point 4 10 to the 9
spaces so you know you get about maybe
six of them wrong and depends on where
that happens you might be in a ok shape
and you know
basically life continues or you're
you're in trouble
and of course as we grow this number of
like if you have an error here and
another error there like you know this
is higher chance of you getting to a
problem and that's why with age we
increase the chance of getting diseases
like hamsters and whatnot of course we
can hear these things from our parent or
it can happen during our lifetime DNA
molecule each base atcg
are less than a nanometer apart of
course the 3d structure so there are
really small molecule you know over the
atcg if you want to read them any
sequencing is that is the method of
reading that code does let you know what
is the code basically associated to this
one when i was trying to dig into these
i realized that okay while reading that
DNA and RNA code it's very important
part of understanding majority of these
diseases the methods that existed for
these are mainly optical technologies so
the way that they do it is that and
that's both for optical technologies and
other technologies is called most of
most of them is called sequencing by
sensitive so how does that work the same
things that I explained that let you
know term one cells we creating the
second if one cell gets into two cells
and the DNA get double-stranded that's a
synthesized part of the DNA they're
using the same trick to read the code so
the way that you do it is you have a
single strand DNA the made of ATPG
you're injecting a TCG in cycle you know
what you're injecting in and you're
building the second strand next to it if
these nucleotides stick here and a only
is T 2 T as you know and see only 6 to G
so if it happens here and you can
somehow detect their reaction then since
you know what you injected in you know
the complementary strand and that's
method called sequencing by synthesis or
SPS historically these methods the way
that you're trying to detect the
a TCG's is by attaching the floor for
some mineral color tag to those atcg
and then doing the multistage chemical
reactions and using a high-power laser
to exercise that floor and taking images
and finding out the proper frequency for
that image and find out if that really
got sticky here or not if the reaction
happened or not and that's the method
that has been used optical technologies
its optical technology and it's in a
different form factor but majority of
them were the same concept those high
power lasers and requirements of a
scanner and a robot etc make the device
really expensive you're talking about
from hundreds of thousands of dollars to
ten million dollar devices average of
$1,000,000 it also makes it which is
slow historically the first time the
methods basement for DNA sequencing to
13 years from 1991 2003 3.8 billion
dollars to read one human genome of
course the price came down since then a
lot and it's been a lot of activities
going on but again the cost per test
across the run reduced to some extent
while the cost of these machines hasn't
changed massively so when I was learning
more about these methods and coming from
electronic engineering electrical
engineering background was thinking
about why they're not measuring the
electrical change of this reaction a
very simple idea of course what they're
teaching up in engineering school is
like you know I and V I multiplied by
these powers that's about energy and I
the current over time so like you know
and here we have a reaction so
definitely there should be some sort of
a change of charge and also there's some
sort of a change of energy so I brought
that idea to head our Stanford genome
Technology Center professor Ron Davis
who is an amazing guy so ron has four
bachelors physics math biology botany
PhD in biochemistry from Caltech
so start with Jim Watson the Nobel
laureate at Harvard and there was a
Stanford professor from age of I dunno
28 29 now I'm talking to in 64 years old
and I'm telling him that like you know
how about we using some sort of a macro
sensors and like no and again while he's
not an engineering electrical engineer
he worked the wire he understand what I
was referring to and what I was
explaining that like we can use some
conductor technology she was very
excited about the potential it can break
the table and then he start telling me
that if we can really build that that
could be very revolutionary that could
be very game-changing because of we need
genetic testing and reading this
information for tons of different
application healthcare is only one of
them as professor mention so he
convinced me I should work on it as my
PhD project I did so I moved from radar
to DNA and while it looks so different
and there was a lot of you know
interesting learning over the course of
past decade but there's a lot of
similarities believe it or not both of
these vast signal-to-noise both of them
you do detection and both of them you do
estimation is a signal processing so
lucky to define defining a sensor you're
designing it you're measuring the thing
and the environment is different of
course here you define designing a chip
that historically packaging of the chip
is supposed to have no moisture around
that here we just inject me the moisture
to the chip so hurry you know it
requires some special treatment but
that's engineering challenges and this
is fine
so that's how I started working at
Stanford genome Technology Center and
chose the co advisor also in the CIS
building which that's another story that
we were working on that
lithography related project the first
two years of my PhD I was developing a
quasi electronic technology based on
that I explained you explained to you
that there's like a no charge that you
can detect or energy so charge is a
multiple versions of this charge that
you can detect one of them is the proton
or H+ ion that is you get release of
that reaction so you can
built a I insensitive field effect
transistor or Express and you know
having the DNA molecules but above that
and then the moment that this reaction
happens that we just talked about
now the proton gets relieved right there
you can you know that works like
changing of the gate voltage and then
you can see that in the IV current a
current voltage curve and you can detect
it over time and you can do it for every
single one of them over time and since
you know what injected in you can really
read the DNA so that's what's quite
exciting we've done similar things also
for showing the energy section we call
the thermal sequencing because there's
some sort of a thermal measurements and
that's just you know three four years
here at Stanford that was doing the
different sorts of a proof of concept of
that one but the majority of these two
technology was were back in 2004-2005
soon we learned that even though it has
some advantages that now we can use a
some conductor chip and reduce the cost
of this device from multi hundred
thousand dollar to probably 50 grand or
20 grand or such still the workflow
workflow is the whole process of really
getting these things is not as easy as
what we like if you want to distribute
it in a larger scale the core concept of
PC in the world of mainframes or
genomics for instance when you turn to
the set pH one of the issues that you're
running into because of your detecting
Delta pH you're detecting the release of
proton ion H+ ion then your solution has
to be in a very low buffer capacity
either oh if you know what buffer
capacity what does mean but you similar
to the capacitors that we have you know
basically we have a high capacity or so
locus and see the same thing exists also
for solutions solutions they're adding
some you know additional materials there
that the basically doesn't allow big
change of pH and for the majority of the
value of related work that's how the
biology works
they usually have stuff like trees and
so on and so forth or in the solutions
keeping the
capacity high now if you wanted to
detect the Delta pH you have to operate
in an environment which actually has to
be low pH so to some extent enzyme
doesn't like it there's some other
challenges that you're running into but
it's actually another problem if you
have a low buffer capacity low buffer
capacity solution the moment that it
touched the air the co2 of the air can
get dissolved here and that co2 get
dissolved create a big Delta pH so your
signal you know it's going to be way
bigger than the signal you trying to
deter so you have to really protect your
liquid from any air and for that purpose
you required a nitrogen tank or Arjun
tank or so on and so forth to reuse them
so that's one additional requirement
also the amount of data that you are
collecting was less than images that
historically people were collecting but
it was more than what we could really
just upload it to a cloud system and
have a decentralized remember we're
trying to really figure out a way to
make something which can be used for you
know really large scale with many people
not just and now to get another like a
me-too version of things for the labs so
we start developing yet new technology
which this time we call it the pure
electronic or direct measurement and
that's really what we developed about
four years at Stanford until late 2010
and then incorporated the company I got
my PhD defended PhD in December 2009
wrote the Tevas right after incorporated
the company in early 2010 license all of
these works that you were talking about
from OPL that's a whole other subject
that we can talk about probably for six
hours you know how to get that one and
what type of like to have a good son as
and uglies exist around like how to deal
with OTL and then we got a lot of
government grants when we were
developing the technology back at
Stanford now I start writing some grants
for the company we given that we had
initial success
they were start giving us money for the
company which was very helpful so got
some seed funding incubator in Menlo
Park from 700 square feet lab to office
upstairs and then shared conference
rooms and restrooms and the rest and
hire some consultants brought some of
the people working with me at Stanford
fantastic FA be aboard 10 Stanford profs
a couple of Harvard and MIT Berkeley
scrapes etcetera we're trying to not
discriminate still we had like 10 times
more from Stanford than other places and
then you know that's that journey
started now it's been close to seven
years six and a half years so we start
building at Stanford we were working
more of the core of the technology it
was more of a like you know
proof-of-concept detection since then we
start building ok well now let's build
the the instrument let's build the chip
that builds the multiple versions of
instruments from a breadboard to a
prototype to start changing the
prototypes to an alpha machine and a
beta machine and a commercial beta
machine etc this is an extremely
interdisciplinary project it's probably
the most interesting project you can
imagine you have we have in our company
hard core chip designers analog digital
like you know we're working on a hired
from Apple and Intel and whatnot we have
people surface chemists we have multi
row biologists we have electrical
engineers for designing boards in the
PCB levels we have microfluidic people
they have you know bio Mattox there's a
there's a molecular biology microbiology
etc etc so it's the whole about ten
different disciplines needs to work
together to make these technologies work
it's been a fascinating right to date we
brought in in the development of the
technology close to 100 million dollar
in half of that was from venture capital
in a seed round size AHB the rest was
non-dilutive capsule is one way or other
and then we have a great pent up demand
from the market you know this is
something it's quite exciting that
people are interest
to you I'm going to give you a little
bit more background about you know in
general the use cases of these and why
did what we need really to enable is
that Ron um remember I was talking about
the pH section story that's a very first
thing that we develop here and we
decided to put it inside and not using
it about two years later back in 2007 in
2007-2008 one day I get a call from
someone and then asking questions about
the technology and I was a PhD student
luck you guys and I had no idea about
like how to talk to a businessman
calling me from outside and asking a lot
of detailed questions and after one hour
of detailed question he told me oh by
the way I want to make sure that not
asking any confidential information I
said oh thanks for letting me know now
as at the end of the call so long story
short there was one of the folks who
were in this business and built couple
of companies in related field we're very
interested about that PhD section
platform requested to license that from
from us from Stanford I was just a
mentor and finally after 18 months of
back and forth he got a non-exclusive
license on that platform during this
time they start also building to
prototype well he had you know again
given his previous experience he also
had money on other things so he could
move things forward in June 2010 June
22nd 2010 he finally I think got the
license but 45 days later we got a news
that that company called iron torrents
got sold for 740 million dollars to Life
Technologies and we're sort of what
exactly happened here like you know way
so the Stanford did a okay deal probably
they could do much better than what
they've done but that's not something
that you know it's impacted me
financially but except that this is
their business
the good news was that I'm Turin ended
up in hand of Life Technologies which is
the main company who did the Human
Genome Project equipment development
year and half later they commercialize
that took in 2011 and then in 2014
Life Technologies got sold to thermo
Fisher that's one of the largest
companies in this field for 15.6 million
dollars and there are rumors about lucky
what exactly their employment piece you
know valued but with a good portion
today
that's the second largest platform that
is offered as a DNA sequencing out there
in the world so majority of the market
is in the hands of a company called
aluminum it is the optical based
platform that commercialized they bought
a company called celexa startup company
called celexa and 2007 and then they
commercialize it and for the past 10
years they've been offering it they have
the range of hundreds of thousand
dollars to ten billion dollar machines
owned my major stake in the market the
second is the islands foreign platform
while again Stanford did was interesting
one is was very for me it was very
fascinating to see that a project that
you are working on and we literally put
it aside we just say like you know this
is not good enough for the purpose of
trying to achieve now is offering and
you know between in oncology that's a
very is probably the most successful one
and is a you know commercially available
product that you can you know go to what
you know you can go to have official
website and you can buy it and you know
many labs are using it and worldwide the
reason I brought it up trying to say
that while we are students here and
working on you know this idea or that
idea sometimes we don't realize the work
that you're doing could be quite yes
quite valuable quite you know worthy of
something not necessarily only from the
financial standpoint but also from the
impact the standpoint from something
that could be like you know we're very
valuable something
exist in the planet Earth when I came to
Stanford as electrical engineer were
thinking about you know I studied a
signal processing and I studied and
that's what that's only thing that it
was considering to really work on I was
not really open to you know exposed to
other stuff except that until I really
started a major and then well it's not
the major the field the work that they
were doing but then I learned that
actually what I learned in bachelor was
frankly nothing you know this is a basic
science that you learn about you know
how we can get yourself exposed to
something different and in my opinion
actually considering is the best major
in the world because of you know both
math and physics in a very practical
analytical way so they can analyze
almost everything that you like to have
so it gives us the opportunity to really
tackle the problems which are not in the
historic electrical engineering field
and be very impactful in fact I think
that the work that historically
electrical engineers were doing are over
they did such a good job we don't need
that anymore
back in days ago professor Tom Lee which
I believe his students teaching one day
he came to class and he says the next
five years
every dog even going to have a cell
phone so working on cell phone wouldn't
be as fancy as you think so the wireless
communication went to a very very high
rise but like it was then after that
like we have an amazing solution and
then if you want to spend your life of
five years and developing specific
things that's going to increase the
efficiency of one of those algorithms
that may be the voice behind the cell
phone gonna get you know two point five
percent improved it may not really
reflect in the impact that you're
looking for long run yes you're going to
get a PhD don't worry about that but
except that you you have you have much
more power to really implement if you're
going to go out of the original field
and trying to implement this knowledge
and know-how in most
generally any disciplinary area so with
that I'll pause for a moment and see if
there's any question if anything we
wanted to talk about before I go to the
next section which is about which is
about you know gin apps run the company
[Applause]
oh so what what we are trying to enable
and what we're trying to achieve a gene
abscess we call it a molecular reader
like one of the applications of the
technology that we developed is the NE
sequencing but it's not only the any
sequencing is actually you can use it
for quite a range of other very small
molecules like DNA RNA proteins or even
cell single-cell analysis and it will be
very impactful to have such a system
especially if it would be low cost cost
matter at the end of the day a lot I'm
going to explain in a couple of slides
why would be fast would be accurate and
easy to use the ease of use is very
important in my opinion and at the end
it has to be portable it has to be
something that we can really have it
wherever we need to have this technology
and the reason is we are living in the
world of biology and everything around
us majority of them like a 95 percent us
is actually violated on the stuff we
made up 38 trillion cells in our body we
have more microbes in our gut than the
cell in the body the coffee that you
drink the teeth the food disguting
the leather that you know this is the
root is they're all like everything that
you see around you this is all all like
you know is that they have molecular
information and today we are blind to it
we don't have an easy way to read that
but this is abundance level of extremely
distributed information that is very
critical and these are very impacting
not only our healthcare but tons of
other applications it's very critical to
be able to read this information in a
low-cost easy to use fast and very
distributed manner that's something that
needs to happen like by genetics or by
somebody else but it has to happen I
have no doubt on that one and this is
something that again we're thinking
about this feature set we have been
focusing on trying to
see how we can enable so you all know
that DNA we already talked about it is
the computer code of life and really
defining a lot of functions of the
everything around us and tensor is the
gene disease or the change in the
mutation but if you wanted to look at
some numbers if you want to look at some
statistics some of these statistics are
extremely interesting and scary for
increase the chance of getting cancer
during our lifetime the first time I saw
that electric freaked out it's more than
40% what I'm 40 percent so means like
you know in this room right now we are
like 12 people we have or 13 you know
people right now sitting here we're
talking about like Sagawa at least five
people going to get cancer during our
lifetime you know if you're thinking
about it it is a little bit you know
serious number if not like an appoint or
one percent chance is a very high number
but the chances of success of a drug
that is been built to diagnose cancer to
deal with cancer it's less than 10
percent you spend 10 years eight to 10
years a billion dollar at the end
starting with ten thousand compound
going all the way to one clinical trial
one to culture art to and cultural tree
if it works only for 30 percent of the
population you have to trash this right
because it's pretty much like a lot of
these is pretty much the blind studies
like you just do these and you pass it
to clinical trials are a version of
really trying to test it in a bit more
meaningful way
because we don't have an easy way to
really look at these markers and find
out if it works for 30%
what is it specific about that 30% if it
works for 30% let's get it dragged out
for that 30% you save the drugs you save
a billion dollars and now the solution
is that is a much smaller solution the
problem is a bunch of smaller problem
you need to only find a solution for the
remaining 70% and so on and so forth
it's called companion diagnostic this
field of really finding a way to get
drawing out it's called companion
not pretty interesting field and that's
one area that is very important how we
can really deal with that but
application of genomics and DNA
sequencing is way beyond healthcare when
we talk about healthcare
there's prognostic prognostic means like
super early diagnostic early diagnostic
that is almost the best way to deal with
something like cancer effective
diagnostic finding the treatment after
you even you know a figure out basically
what's wrong with a person let's use the
example of the cancer that you've been
focusing on should we use chemotherapy a
or chemotherapy or surgery or
radiotherapy you cannot do all of them
you can kill the patient so the question
is that which one you want to really
effectively implement so finding the
effective treatment then monitoring the
treatment throughout the process finding
F is the number of bath cells the cancer
cells go really down or not right now
we're just likelihood basically doing
your surgery and do a chemotherapy on
top of it and looking at the temperature
so do you feel well and he or she was
either yet I would do well but oh good
and then six months later one year later
two year later you hear about remission
because even some some amount of those
cancers are left behind then they start
replicating and you're still in trouble
or the cancer cells will start
developing drug resistance after they
start injecting these things and then
they don't responds anymore and those
little remaining ones are still quite
sort of problematic so monitoring
through the treatment and of course
finding the effective drug as we talked
about to really find out what is unique
about these patients what it's about you
know their gene marker and have been
numerous amount of clinical studies
who's shown that actually with you gene
martyr you can find out which drugs
might be more effective for you there's
a company actually the neighborhood of
gene abscess called genomic health for
the past 15 years they had I don't know
how many but a lot of you know clinical
trials and papers and whatnot
we've shown for example they started
with the top three cancers for example
for breast cancer they're shown that in
80% of women with breast cancer
after surgery they do not need radio
doesn't make any difference for them
with all of these studies to do
radiotherapy or chemotherapy but the
field has been you know advised by
doctors and been and this is really bad
not only for the healthcare system but
also for the patient themselves and this
is really impacting the body if you're
taking video therapy once in your life
for cancer a then you cannot take it
later on for another type so it has a
lot of downsides as well so all of these
are in healthcare but let's talk about
some completely non healthcare
application one of those would be
agricultural biology today we have more
than 900 million people suffering from
hunger around the globe from UN and
every places that are providing the data
the world population grows by 2050 we're
going to revert about 10 billion the
hunger population from 900 million or
about a billion going to get doubled we
use most of farmable land so it's not
like you know what we can go and
redefine new lands to just farm the only
way to feed the world is really to
increase efficiency of every acre of the
land and I'm not talking about GMO I'm
talking about personalized farming I'm
talking about like how we can increase
efficiency that you don't lose weight
and you know fruit and whatever we're
hoping to harvest at the end of summer
that is really happening a couple of
years ago in Florida and couple of
estate next to it there was this virus
get to the citrus farms and you know 13
billion dollar loss that was a serious
like because of if they could catch it
early when the disease outbreak is
happening I mean similar to human
disease outbreak that can happen to
other stuff as well if you could capture
is early you could really save a lot of
those fruits and money and you know food
so this is one of many applications that
you want to really be able to do smart
farming personalized farming find out
okay well where you want to where you
need to do what what's the type of
yes and whatnot other application food
testing you want to find out if the food
is good or not if you just want that
today if the food is going bad in
whatever Costco and JC and how do they
do that they can't they just like to
make a decision and you can cause people
you know it was reported 2015 forty
eight million people in US only got sick
because of food-related poisoning
different type of food issues that's a
very serious number and we don't have a
solution because if you want us to take
this sample and send it to a lab and get
the result four months later that just
doesn't work the food like you know
doesn't food against the not going to
even remain until then we got one is one
of these very large companies in the
food industry reached out to us they
were saying that they have these trucks
of food coming from Canada border and
then they wanted to find out the source
and safety of the food and they just
can't today and they were doing research
and talking to some people actually they
reached out to folks with Harvard I
don't know why not Stanford but that
person knew about that so he's a big
member connected basically them to I so
that's one of the other area front big
security environmental when I was back
at Stanford we were doing the project
with Brazil looking at corn to find out
which one is the better biofuel and so
on and so forth right now we have like
you know people who reached out in
desert lab there's an oil company trying
to look at the algie's who are creating
corrosion is oil pipeline and they
wanted to really like you know identify
the type and be able to deal with that
there's a professor in Mexico making
tequila you know he's starting a company
and he wants to really find out which
one kinda better make it a little cooler
there's so many applications the number
of applications are literally endless
and in a multiple area in again not only
healthcare but a lot of applied markets
and of course in top of all of this is
research is discovery to understand to
better understand the biology to better
understand what
none in the world so with all of that
where we are standing today we are still
in a very early days the total world
population who's done any sort of
genetic testing or genome sequence is
basically less than 0.005 percent how
many of us in this room have done
genetic testing not 2010 me which is
different story but like in the series
genetic testing to find out if we are
getting in cancer now how many of us our
families are doing that and we are part
of the real part of the privileged
section of the society so it's really
early days it's a lot of potential
interesting that and a number of life
science and math searches labs which
they need these is about four hundred
thousand of them only three thousand can
afford to have this massive big machine
so we think the problem is the mainframe
to mobile transition similar to what
happened in the computer industry you
know in the left side of course at the
top you see the mainframe computers you
know it was prior to our days and of
course went to the PC and to laptops and
iPads and iPhones and now your iPhone is
much more powerful than old PC in the
bottom left side you see this this is
most telling instrument out there cost
about a million box you know with about
$100,000 a maintenance fee 700 pound 40
by 50 by 30 inches as I mentioned there
are machines which is cost 10 million
dollars but this is a million dollar
version and that again 700-pound
requires the big server next to it and
run in a very special condition in the
right side this is our device which is a
foot pedal and iPad is portable last
class couple of years ago when I gave a
talk here I brought it with myself today
I didn't because it was coming from
somewhere else but if the little machine
that you can carry it it's pure some
conductor base there is no optics
involved there's no robots all
integrated and the core of that
technology is some conductive chip that
they have some of those chips here
oh yeah I can have a different number of
sensors on that ship but I can I use for
example this one and here you have
millions of sensors right in the middle
area here and the top of that this is
like a three layer structure so it's a
sensor right in the middle and then you
have these plastic in top which has a
microfluidic Channel
that's basically where the sample goes
and you're sitting in top of all these
sensors and underneath you have the LGA
which basically read the information
from the chip and that little machine
supports this chip and that machine is a
social standing machine it doesn't need
a computer it already has a computer
inside of it has a terabyte hard drive
in it it has these wires but you know
what while kind of wireless connected to
the cloud it's a pretty powerful machine
from that standpoint and it supports T
and this is the one who does all of the
reading part and the data coming off
these one and goes through the cloud and
now if you have that then you can do a
lot of interesting work in all of those
applications that we were talking about
well DNA sequencing market by itself it
seems to be pretty amazing market from
the JP Morgan and UVs if it is a more
than twenty billion dollar market 2015
going to be less than 50 by 2018 that's
assuming those big machines a lot of
people believe that if you can really
shrink the size and make it easier to
use and distribute it is going to be the
next hundred million dollar technology
business in fact actually that article
is about the work that I described
earlier about the pH detection that some
conductor machine wrote on that front
one of many applications is cancer one
of the many applications in cancer is
early detection this is a paper from
PNAS processing of National Academy of
Science which probably after Nature and
Science in the world of science is a
really good place to publish 2008 that
shows basically
the progress of cancer over time
starting from one in cancer cell and
start growing and making like and water
and water a number of that go into the
early carcinoma and advanced carcinoma
and then go to metastases and usually
when go synthesis is quite challenging
to the face even so it's very important
to be able to capture it early depends
on the disease but in general about the
cancers it takes about thirty years I
mean there are sensors who are effective
and literally kill someone in two weeks
but again in overall if you want to look
at the average is a very long time so
it's super important if you can catch
captain captured early
I like to coat by dr. Schneider who is
the head of a Sanford genetics
department and director of Stanford
center for genomics and personalized man
you know the closure he's a member of
the company as well he's talking about
if you look at the industrialized world
is about the billion people of course in
China we have more than billion people
in India more than billion people if you
want to just do once a year and wall
checkup of a genetic testing at $100
attacks which is much more acceptable
for insurances and people and everybody
else to pay for that versus today
doesn't exist and is a multi-thousand
dollar for a billion people that's a
billion that's 100 billion dollar
recurring business every year and that's
really representing where we are with
just starting this amazing field so I
stopped here if there's any question
happy to answer but in general a very
much encouraged of our friends in the
department to really use EE background
in a lot of amazing fields that they
need our expertise thank you very much
[Applause]
if you don't take that nine out of ten
companies failure early stages of
development liking the start a few years
I mean my question is what did you
exactly do is to make sure that you're
the one sixteenth among all those
companies who they want to do the same
thing as one thank you that's a good
question I think I don't know the answer
what we did to make sure that's not the
case what I can guess is we were trying
to be extremely clear with ourselves
that you know we're not drinking our own
kool-aid we are very we are really
trying to get everything ready before we
want to like you need to basically crawl
before you walk and walk before you run
a lot of these companies I think they're
just getting super excited super early
about you know there's a oh there's a
five billion dollar market about
something and does I'm going to be hyper
about our world which are not
necessarily this is not
there's nothing causal relationship
there right so I think the question is
do you have something which truly make a
difference you're the right person to do
that and can you takes really the right
steps to do that we have I mean as an
example back in 2006 when I was doing
the management science degree we wrote a
business business plan especially on DNA
sequencing with a group of four other
people and at the end of that the people
who are giving grades to us
there were V sees you know there's a
very good course I recommend you guys if
you have the time to get it by donations
there as well as all dates but you know
MS&E 273 because venture not venture
formation but something like that Amazon
is 273 anyway back then Steve
Steve Blank and a few others were
teaching the course
Audrey McLean etc it was amazing course
so at the end the professors were not
giving you the grade they were getting
receives from them from Senator Rose
coming and listening to you and they
were given grace to you so some of those
folks were interested enough about what
we're doing we were based on the
business plan we said like we want five
million dollar and we want to build one
working sensor in the scale like a new
unit small scale and one of them says oh
you know I'm interested to invest here
so an definitely I got very excited and
I thought that okay well that's the time
to go and start a company went and told
OTL so technology licensing and said I
want to license these and so on and so
forth
then it went to my advisor my fishes
fight advisor and it's all up you know
there's great opportunity we can start
even and he told me that we just got the
NIH grant a five years NIH grant it
multi you know a million dollar
connection and it's only like why why
you wanted to go under the pressure of
disease while we already have the money
to really develop it in an in-house and
this is early so let's just do risk it
here in school and of course yes there
were risks for example there was a
company who got a license from up and
got sold for seven hundred forty million
dollar but let's put that aside that was
a great advice in my opinion so from two
thousand six thousand seven until we
really started a company that was three
four years later but we got much more
data points that we knew this is working
now to in a much higher confidence level
again this is a very interdisciplinary
complex a whole field but that that
helped a lot and then and we were trying
to take the very same approach as we
were going forward you know in my series
a for example like you know there was a
lot of investors who are trying to give
you more money that's what we wanted we
thought that you want to raise twenty
million what there were some investors
will turn to give up 50 and we're trying
to really push back and said hey why
5000 you probably need it but okay well
yes we may need it but we're going to
back why we need to get it today from
you and then when I saw that dynamic
then I even asked the people that you
know what I said 20 but I should I don't
120 I would only ten because of her
apparently interested party so why
should I hit on twenty now and then I
chose the the party who was willing to
work with me on a lower amount and the
second one would be in my hand to decide
if I want to raise that money or not so
really being able to have a lot of you
know again baby steps and control the
steps I think that that helps
[Applause]